für neun euro quer durchs ganze land
werden olian zeit mitbringt der kann
sich mit dem günstigen bahnticket teil
des energie entlastungspaket es
touristisch verlustieren zum beispiel
bis nach sylt sie wissen das ist die
nordseeinsel mit dem edlen rufe heimat
und urlaubsort der reichen und schönen
hummer und kaviar statt currywurst und
pommes so das klischee zumindest das war
vor dem neuen euro ticket denn zumindest
in den sozialen medien hat der sturm auf
sylt bereits begonnen
klappt die sandbänke hoch schneidet die
strandkörbe fest sie kommen
egal ob lingens backen rocker oder the
walking dead und das netz macht sich
schon jetzt schlapp über den proleten
sturm auf die sylter schickeria das
eiland der reichen und schönen in der
ernst der ballermänner und frauen
schluss mit schampus schlürfen in der
sansibar kein platz mehr für luxus
shopping vermutlich bleibt die nordsee
bonzen schon jetzt der edle fisch haben
im halse stecken vor angst zeit für
einen neuen text zum erbte klassiker
westerland und
alle
[Musik]
ich weiß jeder 2
halli galli in hörnum und nun in kampen
einige user erinnern sich sogar noch an
die chaos tage auf sylt im jahr 1995
damals war das schönes wochenende ticket
für 15 d mark eingeführt worden
unzählige punks und linksautonome
änderten die schickimicki insel
sorge auf sylt wohin mit den fire maßen
das land schleswig-holstein versucht
noch verzweifelt auf die anderen schönen
urlaubsdestinationen fehmarn lübeck oder
flensburg hinzuweisen zuspielt die züge
rollen schon richtung nadelöhr
hindenburgdamm hier ist es zur
sommersaison er schon überlaufen jetzt
droht der touri kollaps und kulturschock
beiderseitig 9 euro 50 für pommes und
currywurst backe da muss der sangria mal
ohne essen fließen egal die urlaubsorte
sind bereit zum sturm auf sylt und
notfalls kann man ja laut diesen
twitter-user eintrag ich hier essen